bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de 7,8 le journal nous sommes le
7 novembre
sommaire le député henri guaino a
dédicacé son dernier livre au centre
commercial parly 2 au chesnay
nous étions sur place vendredi dernier
l'école militaire de saint cyr a fêté
ses 50 ans une cérémonie a eu lieu avec
l'ensemble des élèves du prestigieux
établissement
et puis celui qu m2 s'est déroulée la
deuxième édition de beaba bois d'arcy
les passionnés de cinéma ont pu échanger
avec l'animateur vincent perrot on
débute avec de la politique on parle
beaucoup de la primaire de la droite et
du centre mais d'autres ont décidé de
s'en passer c'est le cas d'henri guaino
député des yvelines
il est venu dédicacer samedi dernier son
livre en finir avec l'économie du
sacrifice au centre commercial de parly
2 au chesnay
notre journaliste nicolas d'andry
étaient sur place
henri guaino à la conquête de l'elysée
le député de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines souhaite se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
sur ce chemin une étape aux chaînés pour
une séance de dédicaces et mobiliser ses
sympathisants eh bien ça avance avec
toutes les difficultés que vous pouvez
imaginer puisque tout le système est
fait pour que personne ne puisse venir
contester la loi des grands appareils
en tout cas moi je suis déterminé à
aller jusqu'au bout parce que je n'en
peux plus de faire de la politique en
acceptant
la vie politique telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui plusieurs soutiens du député
illinois sont venus à sa rencontre pour
échanger
j'espérais qu'il allait enfin voler de
ses propres ailes et quitter le giron
des prépublications peut dire le débat
qu'on a actuellement dans les dents
certains partis politiques c'est de ces
de passer au dessus des clivages gauche
droite parce qu'il ya des choses très
bien à droite et les choses très bien à
gauche il faut il suffit maintenant il
faut maintenant il suffit mais il faut
surtout maintenant être intelligent
considérant le clivage gauche-droite
dépasser henri guaino souhaite bousculer
les lignes politiques avec des
propositions économiques pour lutter
contre le laisser faire aujourd'hui la
voie qui vaille est entre ceux qui vous
disent il faut s'adapter
ce qui veut dire subir et ceux qui vous
disent ce qu'ils croient profondément
qu'il faut nous donner les moyens d'agir
dans le monde tel qu'il est est ce que
nous pensons vraiment que la concurrence
peut résoudre tous les problèmes de
l'économie et de la société
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable mais
ce livre dit que non ça n'est pas
raisonnable sur le renouvellement de son
mandat de député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines henri
guaino prendra une décision après la
présidentielle de 2017
vendredi dernier l'école militaire de
saint cyr a fêté ses 50 ans une
cérémonie a eu lieu avec l'ensemble des
élèves du prestigieux établissement
l'occasion pour ses dirigeants de
revenir sur son histoire sur fond de
roulement de tambour
reportage d'anne laure blandine c'était
il ya 50 ans les lycées militaire de
saint-cyr rasé en partie pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale rouvrait ses
portes sur décision du général de gaulle
une date importante que l'établissement
a tenu à commémorer une grande partie
des 750 élèves ont participé à la fête
malgré la pluie c'est quand même un
événement important pour nous comme
toute commémoration d'ailleurs parce que
justement la force de cet établissement
repose sur son histoire et cette
histoire est lourde et chargé de sens
l'école de saint cyr a vu le jour en
1686 sous louis xiv
elle était à l'époque réservé à
l'enseignement des jeunes filles
c'est napoléon qui la transformera en
lycée militaire
aujourd'hui 70% de ses élèves sont
enfants de militaires si vous deviez
symbolise essai d'école par un mot ça
serait lequel
alors peut-être rigueur parce que c'est
un mot qui revient souvent chez les
anciens élèves qui sont partis de
l'établissement 100 % de réussite au bac
et une mention pour 84 % des élèves des
statistiques hors norme qui séduisent de
nombreux parents le lycée reçoit
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus de candidatures
qu'il ne peut accueillir d'élèves
mais au delà des notes l'établissement
défend une culture du savoir être je
récuse pas seulement une question
d'excellence académique c'est aussi
l'excellence dans le domaine du
comportement c'est aussi l'excellence
dans le domaine du savoir être et
surtout une école qui a malgré tout
évolué même si on peut penser que son
lourd passif historique là on crée un
petit peu dans le passé pas du tout des
méthodes pédagogiques qui sont actuelle
des enseignants qui tournait qui
viennent et repartent régulièrement de
cette école et donc à une école qui est
qui connaît des pédagogies de 2016 avec
des tableaux numériques qui ont remplacé
des tableaux a créé cette année le lycée
de saint cyr a ouvert des filières
technologiques un bac sti 2d et un bts
réseaux et systèmes numériques un juste
équilibre entre tradition et innovation
et on reste dans l'actualité militaires
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi un de
nos militaires français a perdu de la
vie dans le nord du mali
fabien jacques était maréchal des logis
chef et il a été victime d'une mine
antipersonnel
c'est muni de ce militaire originaire de
trappes est décédé des suites de ses
blessures
on passe à une info un peu plus légères
vous connaissez sûrement mike horn
l'aventurier suisse qui lie voyage à
travers le monde
eh bien nous avons le nôtre dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ils s'appellent jacques
draperies élégant courtois
il a effectué plusieurs expéditions en
amérique latine il a décidé de publier
un livre en décembre 2015 pour partager
son expérience et ses sensations nicolas
landry est allé à sa rencontre
c'est cette photo là c'est une
c'est une vue de la cordillère blanche
prix de la cordillère noir un bruyant
courtois au sommet de sa passion avec 24
ascension à son actif jacques draperies
a parcouru l'équateur la bolivie le
pérou et l'argentine entre 5000 et 7000
mètres d'altitude
de quoi avoir les yeux dans le ciel des
andes d'après le titre de son livre
tous les soirs après chaque ascension
j'ai toujours j'écrivais toujours ce que
le choses un compte rendu de la journée
et puis après la conca ouah je me suis
dit tiens je vais je vais relire mes
petites menottes et puis je me suis dit
je pourrais laisser une petite trace
pour ma famille donc j'ai commencé à
écrire écrire un livre paru en décembre
2015 ouvrage retrace les expéditions
américaine de l'alpiniste entre 2006 et
2013 en partageant son expérience
comment on s'y préparer comment on
s'acclimate donc au début c'est
l'organisation comment on organise une
expédition
quand on doit tout mettre en mettre en
place et ensuite raconté tout ce que
j'ai pu ressentir pendant ses pendants
ces expéditions et les erreurs que j'ai
fait malgré mes connaissances de la
montagne avec des vents de près de 150
km heure et des températures avoisinant
les moins 35 degrés des situations
périlleuses peuvent apparaître
il arrive un moment où il faut prendre
des décisions lorsqu'on est dans un dans
un environnement qui est difficile une
tempête c'est arrivé la première fauche
partie au pérou on s'est retrouvé à
sciez à plus de 6000 mètres dans une
tempête de neige il est tombé 50 cm de
neige en une heure et demie deux heures
il a fallu faire demi tour
aujourd'hui on j'ai appris à doser à
deux aimants et fort je me connais très
bien en montagne comme comme dans
l'effort physique et
et en fait on puise dans le mental pour
faire face à ce genre de situation
attiré par le défi des sceaux mais la
découverte de la nature
jacques draperies pourrait repartir en
expédition pour accroître son palmarès
montagneux et on parle à présent de
cinéma et plus précisément de bande
annonce ce samedi se tenait à bois
d'arcy la deuxième édition du festival b
à ba le public a pu échanger sur la
cinquantaine de bande annonce présentée
avec l'animateur vincent perrot retour
sur cette soirée avec mélanie poker
séance de cinéma un peu particulière
pour ses 400 spectateurs cinéphiles ou
curieux ils venaient découvrir des
bandes-annonces bois d'arcy organisé la
deuxième édition de son festival b à ba
c'est comme ça en fin de compte qu'on
voit au cinéma une bande annonce apporte
beaucoup pour nous donner une idée du
film je suis revenue cette année parce
que nous avons participé à la première
édition l'année dernière on a beaucoup
aimé on a trouvé que c'était vraiment
sympa sauf tiff c'est très plaisant de
voir de revoir des annonces de films
anciens et surtout des bandes-annonces
qu'on n'a jamais vu une cinquantaine de
bandes annonces étaient proposés
d'époque ou d'aujourd'hui western course
automobile comédie ou encore film
romantique une sélection réalisée par le
parrain
ce qui est amusant c'est que depuis la
première édition de l'an passé je ne
vois plus les bandes-annonces tout à
fait de la même façon c'est à dire
simplement à titre personnel je les vois
avec toujours une petite arrière pensée
bois d'arcy
je les regarde et puis je me dis tiens
celle là serait pas mal pour bois d'arcy
c'est à dire que là ça fait un an que
j'y pense
des anecdotes historiques ont été
partagés tout au long de la soirée par
vincent perriot pour prouver cette année
encore que la bande annonce est un art à
part entière
l'académie du football club de trappes
lance sa deuxième saison dédiée au
soutien scolaire pour les jeunes
footballeurs un soutien gratuit avec une
nouveauté cette année l'apparition du
numérique pour acquérir ces tablettes le
club de trappes a reçu des aides de la
préfecture et de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on écoute la réaction des élèves face à
ce nouveau dispositif
facile car la question
après si tu arrives pas et tout en bas
les cris rappels de cours et après et
explique comment comment ça marche
au début je trouvais ça difficile et
après je fasse il fallait que le premier
j'ai fait
si copé parce que j'ai pas été attentive
qu'on apprenne et 16e 20h12
vérifier après tout les tous les autres
y tout le monde c'est la force de ce 7 8
le journal merci de nous avoir suivis
prochaine édition mardi à 18 heures
je vous souhaite bonne soirée à tous